Vous pouvez faire une autre chose pour vous empêcher
de vivre les symptômes d'Alzheimer,
même si la pathologie est bien déclenchée dans votre cerveau.
Cela est lié à la plasticité neuronale et la réserve cognitive.
Souvenez-vous, avoir Alzheimer
est finalement le résultat de la perte de synapses.
Le cerveau moyen a plus de cent billions de synapses,
ce qui est fantastique ; nous avons beaucoup de matière.
Ce nombre n'est pas statique.
Nous gagnons et perdons constamment des synapses
via un processus appelé plasticité neuronale.
Quand nous apprenons quelque chose de nouveau,
nous créons et renforçons de nouvelles connexions neuronales,
de nouvelles synapses.
Durant une étude sur 678 nonnes
ayant toutes plus de 75 ans au début de l'étude,
suivies durant plus de deux décennies,
on leur a régulièrement fait passer des examens médicaux, des tests cognitifs
et à leur mort, leur cerveau fut autopsié.
Dans certains de ces cerveaux,
les scientifiques ont fait une découverte surprenante.
Malgré la présence de plaques, de nœuds et de rétrécissement du cerveau --
ce qui semblait incontestablement être Alzheimer --
les nonnes qui possédaient ces cerveaux n'avaient montré aucun signe
de la maladie durant leur vie.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Nous pensons que ces nonnes avaient beaucoup de réserve cognitive,
elles avaient plus de synapses fonctionnelles.
Les gens qui ont plus d'années d'éducation formelle,
un degré d'instruction plus élevé,
qui participent régulièrement à des activités mentalement stimulantes
ont plus de réserve cognitive.
Ils ont une abondance et une redondance dans leurs connexions neuronales.
Même s'ils ont une maladie comme Alzheimer
qui compromet certaines synapses,
ils ont beaucoup de connexions de secours
et cela leur permet de ne pas remarquer que quelque chose ne va pas.
Imaginons un exemple simplifié.
Disons que vous ne savez qu'une chose sur un sujet.
Disons que c'est à mon propos.
Vous savez que Lisa Genova a écrit « Still Alice »
et c'est tout ce que vous savez à mon sujet.
Vous avez cette connexion neuronale unique,
cette unique synapse.
Imaginez que vous ayez Alzheimer.
Vous avez des plaques, des nœuds, une inflammation
et des microglies qui dévorent cette synapse.
Quand quelqu'un vous demande qui a écrit « Still Alice »,
vous ne vous souvenez pas
car cette synapse dysfonctionne ou n'existe plus.
Vous m'avez oubliée.
Et si vous en aviez appris un peu plus à mon sujet ?
Disons que vous ayez appris quatre choses.
Imaginons que vous ayez Alzheimer
et trois de ces synapses sont endommagées ou détruites.
Vous avez encore moyen de contourner les décombres.
Vous vous souvenez de mon nom.
Nous pouvons résister à la présence de la pathologie d'Alzheimer
en utilisant des chemins qui ne sont pas encore endommagés.
Nous créons ces chemins, cette réserve cognitive,
en apprenant de nouvelles choses.
Idéalement, nous voulons que ces choses soient aussi riches de sens que possible,
utilisant la vue, le son, les associations et les émotions.
Cela ne veut pas dire faire des mots croisés.
Vous ne voulez pas seulement retrouver une information déjà apprise
car c'est comme emprunter des rues familières, connues,
naviguer dans des quartiers que vous connaissez déjà.
Vous voulez paver de nouvelles routes neuronales.
Développer un cerveau résistant à Alzheimer,
c'est apprendre à parler italien,
rencontrer de nouveaux amis,
lire un livre
ou écouter une super présentation TED.
Et si, malgré tout cela, un jour on vous diagnostique atteint d'Alzheimer,
voici trois leçons que j'ai apprises de ma grand-mère
et des dizaines de personnes que je connais et qui ont cette maladie.
Le diagnostic ne signifie pas que vous mourrez demain,
continuez à vivre.
Vous ne perdrez pas votre mémoire émotionnelle,
vous comprendrez toujours l'amour et la joie.
Vous ne vous souviendrez pas de ce que j'ai dit il y a 5 minutes
mais vous vous souviendrez de ce que vous avez ressenti.
Vous êtes plus que ce dont vous vous souvenez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)